people don't just use one device
interact with your app they switch
between laptops tablets and phones every
day with cross-device sign-on you can
keep your users engaged and reduce
drop-off because once a user signs in
with Google they grant consent across
all their devices take a user who signs
in with Google on the fancy website and
adds items to their cart but isn't ready
to check out yet
later they open the fancy app on their
Android or iOS device and they're
automatically authenticated which means
they're taken to the same state as
earlier with the items already in their
cart and now they can complete the
purchase
fancy results show that users who sign
in with Google are more profitable for
fancy with an order value that's 14%
higher than average and it doesn't just
impact purchasing because maybe you've
tailored your site to be user specific
preferences and now that users custom
experience will automatically appear
across devices it works across platforms
because each of your mobile apps and
your website have a client ID and these
climate Dee's live together under one
project in the Google developer console
this way we know which clients are
associated with our project and that
means that all you need to do is make
sure that immediate mode works on every
platform that you use and will take care
of the rest so to learn more about cross
device sign-on check out our developer
documentation